I think that the fine itself is probably
unsurprising but the scale of it is
surprising why you aren't surprised by
the fine itself you know a couple of
reasons it feels to me as someone that
has been knocking around in the internet
for over 20 years
despite her this youthful looking
appearance that we have now reached a
place where the monopoly position of
power is so extraordinary that something
is going to give and there is going to
be more critical kind of appreciation of
what exactly the internet landscape is
and should be so the fact that google
has been really looked at in detail
doesn't surprise me and therefore when
you are going into such depth of
complexity and looking at the way their
algorithms work and how we as consumers
are being faced with information it's
it's unsurprising that this is a time
that now has meant that we're looking at
these questions much more deeply but the
scale of the fine has surprised you yes
I mean I'm not an expert in EU law in
the way that these things get worked out
but it's clearly a big big chunk of
money and will surprise the u.s. you
know so on who sits on the board of a
Silicon Valley company and Twitter I
have been surprised as I've said to them
at the the lack of interest in a way and
what a lot of things that are happening
in the world and I think that it's
interesting to see how Europe can now be
reacting to some of the US tech
dominance how do you think the u.s. is
going to react to that and in particular
some of these other tech beer moths the
likes of Facebook and and so on who
dominate Amazon they dominate great
sways of the landscape everywhere I
don't have an answer in a crystal ball
which seconds there's definite think
this is going to happen I think it's
quite easy to jump and lump all those
companies together and they're actually
to me behave quite differently and have
very different models behind them I mean
yes data and that commercialization is
at the core of it but they operate in
very different ways so I don't know
exactly what it means for those other
companies but I think it was starting
already but Europe is certainly moved up
the agenda and importance for those
Silicon Valley beer moths I think that
there's no hiding now from the fact that
they are going to have to be responsible
in a different way I would know
be surprised if there was much more
heavy regulation from many different
angles and ultimately probably going to
be looking at how and if these
monopolies should survive as they are in
the future that's a really interesting
point there you think Google ultimately
could face breakup along the lines of
something like a and T AT&T was in the
past yeah well it's been talked about a
lot hasn't it about all these companies
like the big telecoms companies and
platforms and should something therefore
give and I don't know and I have to said
an or my own personal position on this
is but I think that again going back to
the original promise of the Internet
what we found exciting back in the late
90s was this idea of a democratizing we
distributive force with lots of
different companies bubbling up the fact
that you could be anywhere in the world
and start something or be anywhere in
the world and have access to something
and it's not I believe as though these
companies of evil they're not waking up
to do a bad job in the morning I think
they're filled with extraordinary people
with huge ambitions for the world but
there is also no doubt that their pace
of growth and the way that they have
controlled and locked down our
experience of the Internet is still
different perhaps to how we imagined it
back in those early days well that said
I mean ultimately the European
Commission says this is all about choice
and that Google has been depriving
consumers of choice how do you reinstate
a situation so there is more choice
without breaking up a company like
Google I'm not going to try and work out
the future of Google I think there much
complexity to that question but this is
probably a first step to realigning
where the power lies and perhaps
thinking that consumers should have more
transparency and oversight of exactly
what is happening in their everyday
experiences of the internet do you worry
that some in the United States
particularly in the white house may
regard this as the first shot in a trade
war with the EU any kind of real
overreaction to what is just a shaking
out of how the internet landscape is
happening is a bad idea you know I think
it would be disingenuous on both sides
to say that the internet didn't need
some kind of corralling and probably
some kind of more detailed regulation
over time and I think that that could be
a positive thing the positive think of
the consumers for business for us as
citizens so I think overreaction from
any side
is a bad thing and we just have to
remember that we are to my mind in this
phase of internet growth it's a bit like
the teenage years you know we have this
rapid expansion something quite
different to how a lot of us imagined it
might turn out has turned out again no
one's getting up to do a bad job to be
evil but I do think that there are now
some misses there is some necessity to
just having more temperate and moderate
look at how the next phase of the
internet might develop